The answer is 3. A combination of 3 bases is needed. Now there are a couple
of ways of figuring this out. Probably one of the easiest but longest ways of
doing this is to actually just test everything out one by one. You can see if
we just write combos of one letter out we only get a total of 4 combinations.
[UNKNOWN]
We can also do the same thing for the
dinucleotide, or two base combination. And remember, GA is
is not the same thing as AG, because, you
know, the order matters here. And we get a total
possible combinations of 16. When we do the same
thing for the three base nucleotide combinations, we see
that we get 64 different ones. And at this
point, we've reached past our minimum of 20 amino acids.
But the shorter way of doing this is to just use a little math. We have four
possible letters and three positions, so we can
raise four to the power of three, which is
also equal to 64 combinations And get that
answer pretty quickly. And so it turns out that
a minimum number, a minimum combination of three letters
is necessary to start coding for all the amino
acids that cell needs to use for translation. And you can see we
actually have room for extra. And we'll see how that works in a second.